irène chaigneau propose voyage sans
passeport
yougoslavie pays les contrastes le
voyageur qui arrive là bas est
impressionné par le côtoiement de la vie
ancienne et de la vie moderne par les
changements de la nature par la variété
des paysages hausse on trouve d'autres
les collines des montagnes la mer les
lacs et bien entendu des villes
celle-ci ce toubib est une cité antique
du ivème siècle avant jésus-christ
philippe ii de macédoine en fit la
coquette coach tommy ce qu'il reste du
palais deux parties nusobee et la pompéi
de la macédoine
elle n'a été mis que partiellement à
zoomer vous y verrez aussi un
amphithéâtre romain du 3ème siècle assez
bien concerne pour l'instant ces visages
extraordinaire et la danseuse la
danseuse dont les gestes vous allez le
voir absolument pas changé
cette danseuse est une des ménades on
peut la confondre avec celle que l'on
vient de voir précédemment sur l'image
vous voyez je ne vous avais pas trompé
une des filles possédait deux dionisio
ce qui semble danser au son au rythme
d'une mélodie perdue rythme éternel de
la macédoine
à
et là bas même le jour des épousailles
les hommes parce qu ils sont courageux
et parce qu'ils veulent le prouve et
vont chercher au loin le pain quotidien
à cheval bien sûr c'est plus jeunes
c'est plus rapide et c'est moins
fatigant
voici la fiancée elle reste au village
entre son père et sa mère le village le
rite veut que le village pleurs que la
jeune fille pleure parce qu'elle va le
quitter
mais la réalité tout autre envoyé chacun
et souriant après tout un mariage est
toujours une chose rezé gays et les
gestes restent ponctuelles mais les
larmes sont rarement de la fête
voici les guise d'ohrid
c'est une petite ville qui a eu à passer
extrêmement brillant
regardez tous ces visages étrange
extraordinaire ce sont des fresques
l'ancienne
ohrid est aussi une ville musée l'envol
d'un pigeon va nous conduire dont aulas
au lac d'ohrid toujours bien sûr nous
n'avons pas encore changé de région où
le plus grand plaisir de nos yeux
c'est l'endroit où on sue ben vous
l'avez vu toutes les maisons sont
blotties d'une compo l'eau où elle
semble chercher le ciel les ruelles sont
étroites et tout y est très propre
rui de fuite au 10ème siècle le centre
de la culture slave
ce fut un centre politique religieux
culturels bien entendu la plupart des
maisons sont construites de bric très
ornementé et voici saint clément elle
date de 12 195
voici les fresques qui étaient enfouis
et qui ont été mises à jour
ce sont les lamentations ou kehl
fresque qui sont tout de même très bien
conservé
oh
et sainte sophie qui fut elle bâtit au
9e siècle sur les ruines d'un temple
antique
les maîtres à qui nous devons ces
fresques avait un style très vigoureux
à
il existe là bas une vierge étrange vous
allez l'avoir mais en attendant vous
pouvez contempler la frise des anges
voici la vierge à la barre pourquoi je
ne sais pas
à 12 km d'ohrid au bord du lac et de
charme
les pêcheurs de pécs annie se servent
d'un équipement archaïque et pourtant il
pêche
on trouve là de la truite saumonée
point très pittoresques comme vous
pouvez en juger et qu'ils semblent bien
loin bien loin au bout du monde
vous voyez comme l'eau est claire et
elle est fort apprécié cette eau par les
bus paisible et nour qui font songer aux
animaux de la préhistoire
ils se prélassent dans l'acte de prêt ce
par souci aux confins des frontières
albanaise grecque et yougoslaves
il aime le regarder il se vautre dedans
ils sont cools vous voyez comme depuis
le début visage n'a pas cessé de changer
ce chemin qui est foulé actuellement par
ces paysans et par leur charrette est
une antique voie romaine qui date du 2e
siècle avant jésus-christ elle se
continue bien sûr aujourd'hui par une
voie moderne qui est une réalisation de
la nouvelle macédoine
celle ci est fréquente et puis vous par
des voitures à quatre roues ni d'où de
moteur et marchante à l'essence
et maintenant voici l'île de rab dans
l'adriatique sa cathédrale est très
belle c'est une ville où il semble que
l'on respire l'éternité les temps
et voici saint-blaise patron de double
ni qu il tient la maquette de double
nique dans ses mains dans sa main gauche
plus tôt et dans sa droite un sceptre en
argent du 15e symbole de la grandeur et
du passé glorieux
le palais du recteur xiiie siècle
mallet directeur du xiiie siècle avec
des chapiteaux merveilleux un portail
gothique une cour intérieure empli de
pigeons
elle fut restaurée au xvème siècle car
il se produisit une épouvantable
explosion de munitions
fontaine de la renaissance sur lesquels
les pigeons viennent toujours boire une
petite merveille d'architecturé et la
rue principale de double nique
c'est un ancien canal qui séparait la
ville et ce canal fut comblé au 16e
siècle
dobrev nique avec ses petites rues
étrange ses balcons serré ces fleurs
tropicales et sa place pour ce livre au
farniente
comme sur toutes les plages c'est jeune
fille en costume
qui croise autre jeune fille beaucoup
plus moderne et qu'elle a votre avis
monsieur plus de charme
de l'époque d'auguste l'amphithéâtre de
poule a avec son arène en forme
d'ellipse pouvant contenir environ 25000
spectateurs
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de l'office de
tourisme yougoslave à paris et le
concours de solange péters montage
pierre michel rey sont jean-paul qui
campoy script u7 andry illustration
sonore dominique valadié